on
911 when you're the operator right
you're the operator the emergency
operator at this point with all your
lines can't you just put the lines in
the screen and not have to memorize
them I would yes yeah yeah you don't
need to do that because you're reading
them as they're they get printed out or
right well some yeah some of some of
it's up there because of the things and
then some of it's not because they
change they have to you know they
they're constantly like rewriting or
they'll do my part before they do the
emergency or they'll do the emergency
before they do my part so it's all kind
of but yeah I mean it's you know you're
able to you know kind of for the phone
calls and stuff like that it's actually
quite helpful because they will actually
run the phone call up there for you so
that you can you can react as if you
would if you were hearing it yeah I
pulled the Brando a few times I would
have like lines written in a book or I'd
have I have the prop guys I go Hey
listen when I'm reciting that Alexander
the Great thing make sure it's in this
book right here on this page at this
height so it looks like I'm reading it
or it looks like I'm you know always
Minds on Criminal Minds um when I was
pregnant in real life I like literally
my brain was just gone like I just it's
like a thing when you pregnant like you
just don't remember anything and so I
would I would write some of my lines
like in the files we'd be on the plane
I'd be like oh suspect just and he's you
know yeah I was laughing I'd be like
guys I have there's like literally
nothing happening upstairs I'm sorry I
worked with an actor once who taped his
lines for his coverage on my forehead
I've I actually put my lines for another
actor's coverage who was a guest star
and I said we always do this we didn't
but I was like we always do this I put
him on there and and he still it
up I was like Jesus dude just read the
lines it's too small mate it's too small
I can't read the lines on the sheet mate
would you like me to write them out well
screw us when we get older right and
we'll be like huh yeah like can you step
back further I think everybody should
have earwigs that's what I think I think
we should just I can't no no have you
tried it I've had to do those like when
I'm singing and stuff before and it
drives me insane I can no no but these
are really tiny and they fit in your ear
they're really but we still to learn our
lines that's our job yeah for you hey
guys I'm doing another live podcast
downtown LA at the Regent Theater and my
special guest for January 24th is
Kristen Ritter Breaking Bad Jessica
Jones this is going to be a soldout
event I know it it's going to be
exciting and uh there's a meet and greet
and so much fun that's going to happen
January 24th so make sure you get
tickets as soon as possible downtown Los
Angeles at the Regent inside of you with
Michael rosenbom with special guest
Kristen Ritter I'm so excited